ragazzi sono veramente un fonico perché
oggi mi è arrivato un pacco che era più
grosso del mio e dentro questo pacco
c'era questo che sarebbe la realtà
virtuale della playstation siccome in
realtà deve ancora uscire me l'hanno
inviata in anteprima io sono tipo
eccitato manco avessi visto selena gomez
nuda da tre a sei bellissimo perché me
l'hanno inviato e sulla scatola gestito
fa vj e questo sì che è un godimento
tipo vedere essere una gomez nuda 3
ciancio le bande proviamo allora come
prima ma direi riprovare ho fatta ma
kakà si tratterà di una cosa estrema
devo preoccuparmi la vertenza è una
fetta non l'ho detto è vietato ai minori
di 12 anni se no di bio anche se non
sembra simulator va bene ragazzi
proviamo a fare il gioco simulator
questi c'erano questi giusto album
ok basta che lo paga bene ora che faccio
questa madonna che figo stand in circle
e book trigger il calcio lo dire anche
la vecchia piano con l'inglese che qua
io sono a livelli di sci è giusto al
pavimento non è più verso il pavimento
come funziona più giusto no no no ho
sbagliato questo non è mai letto bene
grazie anche nei panni resettare il
pavimento fammi resettare bar mente una
apposta per un bar perché non fanno
sella come tv ar che problemi se sei
felice tu lo sai batiste ma rimaneva a
casa non so perche cio grazie la prendo
ovaie 15.30 l'aveva aprendo i lavori a
ok non sorin avevo capito
fate vobis suoi ragazzi la cosa più se
si abbia mai fatto sul canale cos'è
pronto pizza non volevo fare da una vita
questa cosa ci bene perfetto di internet
cos'è lo specchietto
ma cos'è era bellissimo 9 orgasmo di
testa ma se ci riprovo un miliardo di
volte non ci riesco come ha fatto a
rimbalzare tornare qua quindi non ho
fatto io e ragazzi non ho mai capito
come si usa le fotocopiatrici non essere
un problema
copiamo questo che bandit bot
bene è bellissimo copie bellissima della
casa di stupendo della terra ho fatto
una coppia 6 frate quartetto in regalo
uno dei soldi mi fate capire cosa devo
fare password 101 mica semplice
prendiamo questa effetto quest'acqua
ragazzi di mister robot possa avviare
non segna c'è chiude complessiva mica
che lavoro di merda cechi del computer
da effettivamente se non accendo il
computer potrebbe essere un problema
bello che io non uso il pugno cioè io
faccio tipo quota based tecnico e
password
101 ciò solo due tasti
e chi come torino
ma no non è touchscreen sorry scritto
tre passi di testa di me ragazzi allora
101 ho fatto quindi facciamo presse
trigger to click
ok posso vedere le mail beh vabbè che
cazzo roma malata rough cuts cancella
tutto grazie alla netta scritto va bene
e posso fare una roba posso prendere
fatto fatto casino che ho sbagliato ma
non aiuto ho perso al riguardo come
finito qua world master aid worker credo
funzioni così la foto che verniciare non
ne sono affatto sicuro va bene in teoria
ragazzi dovrei riuscire ma perché ci
sono delle ciambelle ammuffite soldi ma
non riesco a prenderle [ __ ] diva ma
come sarebbe possibile ma la lega ma
vanta già stava schiacciando non c'è
bisogno di soldi qualcuno ci ha per caso
selena gomez proprio che secondo me ci
sta bene può attendere ecc
ma cosa ma come fai tu non ce l'hai le
mani usa la palestra enti che cos'è sta
roba flag no flags bot
ok dentro bene cos'è stata ma cos'è flap
i bot
va bene purchè i ragazzi miei questo a
casa mia io lo chiamo lavorare sodo e
poi non è diverso da quello che faccio
io come youtube ma [ __ ] devi
essere allenato cioè anni e anni di
preparazione bastava ecco infatti balene
gr grazie per aver provato questo cd non
la fotocopia del cd che mi serve avete
presente
clonavano i film ecco perfetto così
fosse così facile sarebbe stupendo dove
vai a sapere che lo piratato will not
work va benissimo allora io come dovrei
cosa vorrei fare a parte gli scherzi
work assignment gente to work niente
javafx mobile
ok può fare il caffè questo è il
paradiso nicchia bellissimo e bello
posso mangiare quello che cazzo vogliono
un ingresso ad avere una per me già così
nella vita reale
rcd
[Applauso]
yes no no no ha detto che perfetto non
me lo versare si no
non l'ho versare si mandava test
conflitti grazie ragazzi sto per fare
una cosa che non dovrei fare ma io la
faccio ha problemi a chiamarsi statue
superbi solo che io adesso ciò che gli
occhiali va bene grazie a queste cose ma
non ne sapevo fare anche quando andavo a
scuola vivremo cedesse nov c'e la copia
pirata
prendi targa porta sfortuna a rovesciare
il sale non va bene dentro dentro è la
madonna 322 milioni di dollari in debiti
sono tuoi e non so mi hai fatto suo
cambiare facciamo 0 facciamo 0
che è successo pagare né rilasciato
perché mi ha lasciato jobs imu letta ma
ritorna di barga trovai a miglia posto
sono diventato esperto lega non c'è
allora posso fissare questi numeri senza
che mi cacci qualcosa che ne so io
perfetto 10 di odio di odio non si può
farselo carcere fa niente cambiamo
lavoro ragazzi proviamo un altra roba
che abbiamo questo gourmet chef io che
faccio lo chef
vabbè maledetto quello che sia capace
con gli amici con queste belle mani ne
ha fatto parola una cosa alla volta cosa
volete che faccia allora si apre l'acqua
ci si lava le mani e acosty cos'è sta
roba perché è cambiato un frigo dove la
modella in tutto questo ok questo è o di
un prezzo perché ti posso mangiare le
cose ci sono io lo chef o salsa piccante
va bene ragazzi lascia perdere proviamo
a cucinare sul serio or the wrap cosa
devo fare
breakfast allora proviamo a mettere
questa ben devo prendere il bacon 20
adoro trovo al decoder con datevi al
petto da tre del back stage siena mi sa
che mira a quel questo questo non è né
campagnola uomo l uomo mi servono l'uomo
nuova allora caffè perfetto esattamente
così si cucina nuovo ragazzi bene allora
questi via è stato sempre lui alla 9 a
posto però così si pronuncia quindi
dobbiamo sollevarlo mettiamolo qua
tutto qua le mani ovviamente a ditelo
che ne sono certo che il freezer da ecco
poi non è che me lo fai cucinarmi
ecco a chance l'indicatore tra l'altro
io prima era andato completamente a caso
formaggio oppure sul piatto tra l'altro
è tutto questo anche visto il lavoro di
merda che ho fatto prossimo fra chiuchiù
difesa chiudi freeter prossimo se lo fai
non farebbe le due mentre blender
flander sarebbe il frullatore si
perfetto frullatore devo frullare le
cose cosa frulla uniamo la bicchiere al
bicher entra pomodori ok ma c'è il
coperchio non certo come nicchia si è
frullato un bicchiere spiega un pomodoro
il bicchiere dentro bicchiere alla
salute ragazzi alla salute destro gas
ecco quel fratello laggiù se per caso
dovesse morire non sono stato io ciao
tizio baffuto che somiglia al mio zio
poi del te ne va bene lavandino il dei
ragazzi è una delle poche cose che nella
vita so fare pochissime fare sulla lite
la pasta ma sta acqua calda
no colle sapone ottino spetta aspettato
perfetto questo peserà buonissimo
ragazzi scaldare mettiamo questo qua
la messa si scambiamo ma chiudi l'acqua
che ti strega chiudi perfetto
in teoria in teoria dovrebbe essere
abbastanza matches titolate cosa devo
fare
la filiera e che ne so io aspetto fermo
lei era sulla nave visto che c'ha la
teiera puoi mettere a cuocere un
bicchiere che si scioglie che si inizia
tutto ciò è anche ragione lo devo
sollevare ma io se tocco sta roba che
succede niente l'affondo no si no
perfetto devo mettere gli scotti ha già
giustamente
previsto ok dove sono i biscotti dove
sono qualche ma ce l'ha poi [ __ ]
frego murray frigo poi questo mare di
una maiala ovaiola cosa faccio quando
metto il biscotto dentro te no no no da
regalo a [ __ ] 11 è uscito leggermente
nero ma e saporito quindi uno che dai
ragazzi e la colazione migliore della
vita barriera che a suo dire che possono
concludere qui per oggi perché è stata
quanto imbarazzante questa cosa ma
parecchio sarà che non è semplice
ragazzi spero che in italia facciamo il
telecomando che chiudo inguardabile mila
presenti al momento era mi piace al
cavallari facebook come sta per iniziare
che sta qua sotto il sottocosta pane
zanzare di di sieri ci vediamo il vostro
video le ragazze
niente tua mancato di mortacci tua